the first by thank you for all for
coming so today I will talk about a very
nice geometric program which is
essentially simplex partitioning and
application to the multi way cut problem
so let's go over go very quickly what
the multi way a problem so it's one of
the one of the two natural extensions of
mini SD card so we get an undirected
graph and we have special vertices which
are called terminals so here they're you
know noted by color so we have the red
terminal the blue one and the green one
and the goal is to find the least number
of edges is the microphone working yes
it is working
so we want to find the least number yes
the least number of edges that once you
remove them you disconnect all pairs of
terminals so an equivalent way of
looking at the problem is kind of a
labeling problem so we want to color
each of the non-terminal nodes for
example like this and this gives us
essentially three pieces in this example
because there are three terminals or
equivalently three colors and edges so
sorry so we have the red piece that
contains the red terminal the blue piece
that contains the blue terminal and the
green piece that contains the green
terminal and edges that have two
endpoints with different colors for
example the dash edges are exactly the
edges you remove and notice for example
that once you remove them you've
disconnected all pairs of terminal okay
so formally we get a graph G special
subset of terminals T of K terminals and
the goal is to partition the vertices of
the graph into K sets let's call them s
1 up to SK the constraint we have is
that the eyes piece contains the eyes
terminal and we want to minimize the
number of edges that cross between the
different pieces so as I mentioned our
if you have only two terminals this
problem is easy it's just
mean SD card so what is known about this
problem so that allows at all actually
were the first to consider the multi
wake-up problem and they actually gave a
very simple and clean combinatorial
approach for it so for example let's say
this is the instance we have and here
let's say we have five terminals so in
order to let's say find a good multi way
cut here so you compute for every
terminal the min cut that separates that
terminal from all other terminals so
let's say s is that mean cut so for
example it's a s 3 is the min cut that
separates the red terminal from the rest
and so on notice for example that there
might be vertices here that do not
belong to any mean cut or for example a
vertex that belongs to more than one one
mean cut and then you just take the
union of all edges in the boundary of
the mean cuts and that's your solution
so this is very easily you can see that
gives this gives it to approximation why
because if this is an optimal solution
which is an actual partitioning of the
vertices of B then obviously for example
the cost of the red piece is at least as
large as the mean cut that separates the
red terminal from the rest and so on so
you get that the cost of Si is at most
the cost of the IPC opt and if you sum
over the cost of all pieces in opt this
is exactly twice the value of the
solution because you counted each story
edge twice so this is a very simple and
very clean to approximation and they
also showed are that if you have three
terminals or more this problem is not
and be not only np-hard but also
apx-complete so this is what was known
for the problem for quite some time
until the work of Kali nesco calif and
Rabbani which gave a completely
different and also very elegant view of
the problem which is more geometric in
nature so they actually constructed the
relaxation for the problem where you
assigned for each
protects a distribution over the colors
or the terminals so one obvious thing
you want to require or force here is
that for example the red terminal will
always go to who also will always get
the color red so if you have the
k-dimensional citrix or in this example
the three dimensional simplex so the red
terminal will correspond to the property
of placing a probability of 1 over the
red color and the property of 0 over all
other colors and the green terminal will
correspond to placing a probability of 1
over the green color and 0 over the rest
and so on and every non-terminal node is
just placed somewhere inside the simplex
ok and so this is a very simple
embedding of the graph into the simplex
where you force each terminal to go to a
different corner of the simplex the
question is um how do you measure the
quality of such an embedding so
obviously you want to look at distances
of points are inside the simplex and
this leads to the following our
relaxation given by cousin Kelly nesco
Carroll of another bunny so if Delta K
is the K dimensional simplex so it's a
collection of all high dimensional
points in the positive ortant that their
coordinates are up to one so the
constraints we have so here I'm going to
little bit abuse the notations and use
the vertex but I'll also use you to
denote the embedding of you inside the
simplex this will make life much easier
so the constraint we have is that every
vertex is embedded somewhere inside the
simplex right and also we require that
every terminal is actually embedded into
a different corner of the simplex and
distances are measured according to l1
distances and the reason you have 1/2
area just for aesthetic reasons because
you want the distance between two
terminals to be one and not two okay so
this is our the relaxation with the
geometric relaxation and an interesting
question is okay so there are lots of
works that actually deal with this
relaxation we'll go over some of them
in a couple of minutes but the question
is is this relaxation the right approach
for this problem so today we know that
the zooming the unique games conjecture
this is actually the right way to
approach the problem so it was proved by
Yuma no comment at all but assuming the
unique games conjecture any integrality
gap for this LP actually translates into
hardness okay so for a very long time
the only integrality gap that was known
was eight over seven given by a point in
calif and very recently i think it was
in last eco this was actually improved
to 1.2 so i assume here that it's a the
number of terminals are grows so its
large so this gives you an exact
behavior but we're more interested in
the case where K is large you have many
terminals so now so this actually means
that if you are interested in the multi
way to cut problem unless you want to
refute the unique as unique games
conjecture you should work with this
this relaxation this geometric
relaxation for the problem so the
question now is given an embedding into
the simplex how do you extract a
partitioning of it essentially a
multi-way card and this actually leads
to a very nice geometric problem which
is at the heart of this talk and
actually at the heart of any algorithm
for multi way cut
so the problem is the following we have
the K dimensional simplex again I have
in the picture only the three
dimensional one that was hard enough
drawing this the four dimensional one
drawing it was a little bit about my
about abilities so what you're
interested in is actually find the
distribution over partitions all right
so what is the partition what is a valid
partition in our case so we want K
pieces s1 up to SK and we want a nice
corner of the simplex to belong to the
eyes piece right so this is what is
stated here and given the distribution
we wanted the probability of separating
any two points in the simplex to be
proportional to half the l1 distance
between the points which is the exact
contribution of the two points in the
relaxation and simply their contribution
to the objective function so for example
let's say we have this is 1 let's say
you have some way of sampling partitions
with this property so you can see for
example this is a valid partition of the
simplex why we have so this is a three
dimensional simplex we have three pieces
the red piece contains the red corner
the green piece contains the green
corner and the blue piece contains the
blue corner so this is valid and now
let's say you have a distribution over
this and it's a simple observation that
just by linearity of expectation if you
have this type of distribution over
partitions with the parameter of alpha
here this gives you an alpha
approximation for multi wake up so this
is a very clean and elegant geometric
question that is kind of independent of
multi-way cot it implies something but I
think it's actually a very beautiful
question it's not clear what's the best
alpha you can get here until this day so
it's not known what the right answer is
and actually not surprisingly all
algorithms besides the greedy
combinatorial one of dollars at all that
gives you two approximation all of these
algorithms actually work in this way
they find distribution over partitions
of the simplex and try to find the best
alpha there is so one thing that will be
very convenient during this talk is
actually to restrict our attention to a
very specific type of edges or
essentially points are in the simplex so
without loss of generality if you have
two points and we want to in the simplex
and we want to ask what's the
probability that they're separated
especially but each one belongs to a
different color we can assume they're of
this structure so you have let's say you
so this is our one point in the simplex
so it's neighbor visa obtained by moving
an epsilon mass from coordinate J to
coordinate I so this is equivalent of
subtracting epsilon from the Jade
coordinate and adding epsilon to the
heights coordinate and this can be
assumed without loss of generality I
don't want to go into the exact details
but this is essentially an outcome from
the fact that you use l1 distances and
given such an edge let's say we can call
it an edge of type IJ we're interested
in what is called the cut density and
this essentially the car density will
determine the approximation factor or
how good the partitioning of the simplex
is so what is the car density so assume
you have an edge that of this type that
you remove you moved while an Epsilon
mass from the Jade coordinate to the I
then if you assume that you can take
epsilon to be as small as you like and
then you see what's the probability of
separating such an edge with respect to
its contribution to the objective and
the car truth contribution exactly half
the a long distance which is epsilon in
this case so it's this limit where you
take the probability divided by the
contribution to the LP objective which
is epsilon so we're interested in this R
parameter which is called the car
density of the simplex partitioning
method so now this crap actually so two
building blocks that were used in
several algorithms so the first building
block actually uses exponential shocks
or competition between exponential
clocks so this is the entire algorithm
so you choose for every color or every
terminal and independent exponential
clock they just need to have the same
rate so let's say the rate is 1 it
doesn't really matter and then if your
point you in the same track you scale
each of the exponential clocks by your
value in that coordinate and you pick
the winning one so essentially the eye
space is all the points in the simplex
where the eyes coordinate scaled 1 so
these are also Exponential's in you
just let them compete in the minimum one
wins so how does this look are
geometrically so if this is the three
dimensional simplex so consider the
point of all the exponential clocks once
we scale them to be inside there simply
so we just divided by their sum so let's
say this is the point Z so the first
question is how does this point how is
it distributed in the simplex and the
answer is that this is actually a
uniform point inside the simplex and so
for example given the today's
realization of the uniform point what is
the partitioning of the simplex it
induces so I think this is this
partitioning let's say for the three
dimensional simplex so one way to view
this again in the three dimensional clay
case is that take for example the red
terminal and draw a straight line that
goes through the Z and take this
remainder and also it's from the green
criminal so you have this line you have
this and from the blue one you'll have
this and this dictates the boundaries
between the pieces and now you can
imagine the point Z floating around
essentially a uniform point inside the
same place an equivalent polyhedral view
of this is you can ask given a fixed
point u where can Z fall such that let's
say use red or where can Z fall such
that U is blue and so on so the answer
is this I hope there's no one colorblind
in the audience otherwise this will be a
little bit hard to follow so if this is
you you get this red area and this is
essentially where if Z falls here then U
is red it goes to the red terminal and
one way to view this is so you know that
if you take all the K corners or indeed
in this case three corners of simply
Center take there convict song that's
the simplex itself so if only interested
in the red color remove the red corner
of the simplex and add you instead and
look at the convex hull of that and that
will be actually the area that if the
uniform point falls there then you will
be colored red
okay so this is a nice interpretation of
of this method but essentially this is
the algorithm these tools are these two
things here that's the entire algorithm
for K dimensions and you can actually
prove that the cab density of let's say
edge of type IJ is at most 2 minus UI n
UJ and remember that you are in UJ are
the values of the coordinates that's
changed okay you can we can also mention
that instead of using this algorithm you
can use the algorithm of Kleinberg and
Tardos for uniform at relay being I
don't wanting to go and I don't want to
go into all the details but for this
purpose it gives the exact same cut dem
city so the second building block was
given by Cali nesco Carlos and rabbani
and what you do there is you pick a
random order over the colors let's call
this permutation pi and you pick a
random threshold where you can think of
it as a radius almost like a radius
uniformly means you're in one and then
you go over all the terminals in the
order of the permutation and you cut an
l1 sphere around it with radius 1 minus
R so this translates exactly to the
following so the ISTEP if you look at
all the unassigned points in the simplex
and their value in that coordinate is at
least R the radius then you assign them
to that color so let's say that
permutation was 1 2 3 so let's say we
chose a single radius we got this piece
so this part of the simplex is red and
say now we should have cut this but this
area was already red so we get only what
is uncoloured will be green and in the
last step in the case step actually
everything that was on colored we just
dumped through the last color so this
will be colored okay so this is da the
second building block and you can
actually prove so this is not exactly
the way it was proved in the original
paper but this is what you can deduce
from there proof and there algorithm
that you
you have an edge of type IJ that removed
an epsilon mass from corn j2i and also
for without loss of generality let's say
we numbered the corn so the first one is
the largest the second one is the second
large and so on so the cob density is at
most one over I plus one over J ok and
this immediately without anything any
extra things gives you one and a half
approximation this is the one and a half
approximation or what is called the ckr
algorithm ok because in the worst case I
equals 1 and J equals 2 for example so
the question is ok so before we get that
so throughout the years and we'll see in
a second what do I mean throughout the
years ago there were many variations of
the CK or algorithm so the most the
common the most common of them was
actually when you distort the solution
so distorting the solution in this case
one way to do this is one can ask ok why
do I choose the threshold uniformly
between 0 and 1 I can choose some
distribution and this perhaps might give
me a better result
so changing the distribution where that
chooses the threshold R or the radius of
the elements fear you cut is actually
equivalent of distorting the solution
right you apply some function G on each
of the coordinate coordinates and then
just use a uniform radius R between 0
and 1 so these verses are extensively
used and you can actually prove in this
case that the cut density instead of
being 1 over I plus 1 over J becomes the
derivative of G at the point you are
this is the value of the coordinate you
change over i plus the derivative of G
in the UJ divided by J ok and again this
is once you write the proof it comes out
very cleanly and almost immediately so
this is one variation that was used and
there were many others for example two
variations that were that will be
interesting for today is one where you
actually say ok I don't choose a single
radius I choose each for each terming or
each color a radius independent
or I sought for example the radius the
radii a choose in a descending order and
that will dictate the order of the
permutation and so on so for example
because you want the solution to be
feasible you want the terminal to always
get its own color so it means that G of
one needs to go to one and also G of
zero needs to go to zero but that's the
only normalization you need for G but
we'll get to things like this in a
couple of minutes so before we all
slowly explain to you what what
algorithms what results are known and
mainly with these building blocks and
this will lead us to the question or
they I know the new are thing I want to
talk about today an obvious question is
why do we need there are so many
building blocks why not just use this or
that so the answer is that each building
block has a different bad case so if you
have two algorithms and each one
performs well on one instance one type
of instances and performs badly on some
other type of instances and you have
saying algorithm number two where these
are actually reversed so by combining
the two algorithms you might get
something that is strictly better than
each of the littles two separately so
I'll give you just a quick example so
for example if you take the first
building blocks that's financial clocks
you choose it with probability 2/3 and
you take the secure algorithm and you
apply a quadratic distortion it means
that you just if you had a value X in
some coordinates you just look at X
square and you choose that with forty
one-third this from what we'll we've
seen so far actually immediately gives
you an approximation of four over three
why because the condensity will be with
probability 2/3 the cut density of
exponential clocks is to minus UI minus
UJ and with probability 1/3 you get the
cut density of the sakura algorithm with
a quadratic distortion which is to UI
over I plus 2 UJ over J and this is at
most 4/3
all right so this improves ckr for
example by using this
blocks so what is knowing about this
problem now that that we were actually
equipped with an understanding of what
the two basic building blocks are and we
can actually understand what's what's
the state or the art of what's going on
with multi Cal not to wake up these days
so as I mentioned by the way all these
results use the geometric relaxation and
essentially find the distribution over
partitions of the simplex with the
lowest cut density that they can so as I
mentioned there's an one in half
approximation by Colleen s Rockefeller
Bangla this is just by applying the
their algorithm and there there was the
work of cargo clients time for open yang
which actually combined two building
blocks which is the secure algorithm
where they had a distortion where you
they actually truncated the radius at
some point and they mixed it with the
secure algorithm where you choose all
the thresholds independently and then
they also had some truncation in the
distribution there and they that gave
them a guarantee of orchid density of
one point three four three eight I
already mentioned the Four Thirds
algorithm where you just mix the
exponential clocks with the C key are in
quadratic distortion and then there was
the work of Sharma and Vaughn Huck where
they actually took this approach and
actually found the best way you can use
it so they what does it mean the best
way so they actually found a distortion
which is piecewise quadratic that gives
you 1 point 3 0 9 and they are a
remarkable thing that they also prove
that you cannot do any better with this
approach so you cannot find any other
distortion that actually gives you
something better than this so now the
question was is this the right answer is
this the best you can hope for so is the
I assume it's the proof of concept we
show that the answer is no and you can
get something which is slightly lower
one point two nine six five and you
actually need to throw in many
or building blocks so you have these two
that were before and you'll also add the
case of the Sakura girl rhythm with
independent thresholds and the ckr
algorithm with descending thresholds and
each of them is with some truncated
distribution over the radius or the
radii you choose and this was almost
proved fully but at some point in the
end they had to use the computer for
their proof but they actually proved
that assuming the computer the number of
the computer complete is correct they
actually had a very fine research and
they actually even see even analytically
bound in the error so this is you can
actually say that this is fully proved
so the question is and the interesting
question so we can see that this gets
more and more complicated so the answer
is is there a simpler approach so I
don't know what the right answer is and
still an open question but an
interesting question is at least for now
is do we need all these building blocks
or is there another way that we can
approach the problem perhaps get
something better or something simpler so
let's are in a few minutes I have left
let's go back and look at what the
distortion was and this is exactly what
the opponent asked me so we have G that
goes from take the coordinates and
outputs and the new value of the podium
right so if we started with a point Q so
then after the distortion we just
applied G on each of the coordinates and
the value of 1 g of 1 has to be 1 and G
of 0 has to be 0 if we want the output
to always be feasible so for example if
this is the simplex if we take the
quadratic distortion means G of x equals
x squared this is how the simplex looks
like so it's not the simplex anymore and
it is squeezed in towards the origin so
one thing one thing that someone can do
or try to do is actually look at this in
a more in a broader perspective and what
does it mean so now if we have a point
in the simplex we don't want to treat
every
separately so every point in the simplex
will now depend on everything else or or
and certainly the entire point so if I
look at the first first coordinate I
look at essentially I don't look only on
its value look at all the values that
you itself and then decide what will be
the value of the first coordinate and
then to decide the value of the second
coordinate again I look at the entire
view all the K values there and decide
what will be the second value of gf for
the transformation and so on so for
example this is one transformation we
use and I'll show you two in a second
but intuitively in some sense this
expresses dependencies between variables
and actually the lower bound does not
hold anymore
so let's the Sharman form that lower
bound that if you take that framework
yes so because that's a very specific
distortion it's the distortion that is
applied coordinate wise for each of the
coordinates so the question is if you
express dependencies or add dependencies
in in the transformation can is it a
simpler way to go below that lower bound
and the answer is actually yes so now it
seems very general how do you construct
such a distortion so as we as we said
before terminals needs to be fixed
points another thing that seems
reasonable to require but it's not a
necessity is what you might call
symmetry so if we have two points you
envy and you just obtain from B by
permuting the coordinates so changing
the order so we know that you go
somewhere here by this general
transformation and so intuitively we
would like to require that you can
obtain V by just transforming you and
then permuting the coordinates in the
same way so this is not everything so
this we require this it's not a
necessity but it's something that seems
reasonable to require from such
transformations so one way to obtain
this is the following and this is
actually the type of transformations we
restrict ourselves to so you giving a
point Q we sort the coordinates and then
you apply some transformation on the
largest value corn
and then a transformation on the second
largest value coordinate and so forth
and after you've done that you place
them back in their order in the original
order in each of these up
transformations might depend on all the
values of that point not the
specific coordinate you're changing and
I won't go into the details but we also
wanted transformation to be well-defined
in the sense that if you have two
coordinates with the same value so let's
say one of them is the largest there
both of them are the largest one you
don't want the value of the output to
depend on how you break ties in the
sorting alright so in that sense this is
well defined and some monotonic
conditions so this is for example a
transformation so this is the largest
coordinated net the second largest is so
so on that actually gives you our 17
over 13 as a proof of concept and this
is smaller than the lower bound so now
you don't need all these four building
blocks
you just apply exponential clocks with
some probability and the CER algorithm
with this global distortion with
dependencies and get something which is
lower than the lower bound of Sharma and
Van Praagh
and the main result is you can get one
point two nine six nine four multi-way
cut using this approach only these two
building blocks and this is almost what
Sharman bontoc got up today you know if
we stop calculating the number here it
will look the same but unfortunately we
looked at the four digits after the
decimal point so slightly worse so I
think two interesting questions here
one more broader question is can
transformations with dependencies
actually help with other problems
because the technique of transforming
the solution then doing something was
used in many problems even in the
literature and it's not clear whether
once you look at transformations that
include dependencies you might get
better results or similar results and
the second question which is more
specific is actually the geometric
problem I described given the K
dimensional simplex what's the best
car density you can get
it so we know it's at least 1.2 and at
most one point two nine seek something
[Applause]
undirected so I'm not sure I mean the
what I call the Sakura luxation
doing some computation things for as K
gets bigger I don't get a sense of the
value of you can get so so are you
referring to what's the best car density
is K increases so four so four three
terminals the problem is known but for
even for four terminals it's not known
what the right constant is but okay this
talk we focused on when K is large let's
say not on so all the algorithms here
actually save shave some factor that
depends on K I do not mention that
because I didn't want to go into all
those details but yeah so there are
actually two types of questions one of
them is what happens when K is large the
asymptotic behavior but even as they
getting the right car densities K
increases it's not clear even for four
terminals what's the right answer is